donc pour changer un peu je vous ai fait
une interview nul
vous avez bougé par le jingle c'est la
première question non la pastèque
c'est une constatation vous avez bougé
par le jingle patrick bosso pas on leur
fait on va le faire si on peut rallumer
ray temps on refait je dois pas bougé
non il faut pas bouger il prend de
montvert donc on refait je vais vous
faire une interview nul
j'ai compris ça
bordaberry ouais je sais parler parce
que les gens ne savent pas c'est que
vous avez un pouvoir comique en plus non
seulement comment ils ne savaient pas il
est très séduisant mais vous avez un
pouvoir comique incroyable partie
alors ça fait partie de votre séduction
est énorme alors attendez je bouge plus
j'aimerais apprendre le vercors
maintenant fait bouger tout ce que
voulait bien leur première question
interview nul donc qu'est ce que vous
préférez passer une préféreriez passé
une nuit avec anne sinclair avec laure
sinclair ou avec bob sinclair c'est pas
nul
c'est pas nul du tout dans une nuit une
nuit lorsque leur sac à une nuit non une
vie assez gentil vous en sentez bien
c est ce que je préférais hitler ou
staline
pourquoi parce qu'il a tué plus de gens
vous n'avez pas demandé pourquoi il est
nul votre interview répondent entre la
peste et le choléra
j'ai pas le droit de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre ah non moi j'aime bien les gens
qui disent quand vous les gens répondent
mieux je trouve ça nul voilà je peux pas
vraiment dit staline si une réponse est
entre les deux voilà très bien est ce
que vous préférez pompidou giscard ça
c'est dur mais c'est que des gens qui
arrivent à répondre moi moi j'ai une
sympathie pour la bonhomie de pompidou
donc
a priori je dirais plutôt pompidou
plutôt pompidou alors maintenant c'est
la question la question clotilde courau
ce type de kuro a inventé une question
elle est adorable
alors est ce que vous seriez prêt en
brasse et 100 fois une paire de
chaussettes sales par amour
non non mais voilà l ouïe voulait la
question pierre bellemare allez-y la
question vannes qui permet de l'art je
veux pas si c'est pire
la question devient bellemare c'est
comme dont la banderille et vous un
vibromasseur cuisse branche sur
l'allume-cigare comment vendre y joue
gros minceur à ses palaces est censé
être là qui se branche sur
l'allume-cigare comment je vendrai c'est
à dire que quels arguments où vous vous
développez auriez pour le vendre c'est
très pratique
voilà alors il faut sauter en touche
j'imagine mais j'imagine bruel à lattes
et dans sa bagnole et arriveront en
disant c'est très pratique
imaginez qu'on vous greffe un cerveau
est ce que nous préférerions avoir le
cerveau de etienne daho de julien
courbet ou de ticky holgado etienne daho
etienne daho etienne daho julien courbet
aussi oui me dit pas aussi tiquer le
garder aussi statique ça passe je me
prépare activement
non mais dès maintenant parce que noir
non après tout le monde moi d'accord
alors elle acquit accorderiez vous le
plus de circonstances atténuantes à un
vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un jeune
qui tapent sur des dieux c'est difficile
une bonne question pas si nul que ça
talent un vieux qui se tape des jeunes
ah ouais c'est parce que vous avez
exactement sait jamais non mais c'est
surtout qu'il ya des jeunes qui sont
consentants oui c'est vrai ou
consentante
alors que les gens sur qui on t'apprend
génération porte fondamentalement
concentrons bonne punition préféré je
dis ça pour nos amis est ce que c'est
d'être peint ces mordus piqué au vif et
pince non mordent non l'enseigné de
pique et non lui ou gif et jaguar vous
avez bien répondu à cette interview